foreign
[Music]
my name is David Simpson I'm a reader in
the welcome Wilson Institute
for experimental medicine in Queen's
University Belfast and I work in vision
science so today I'm going to talk to
you about some of the work we've been
doing using single cell RNA seek to
understand their cellular basis of
several
um eye diseases
so hopefully
um after hearing about the various
examples I'm going to talk to you about
it will help particularly people who
are new to the field guide their use of
single cell RNA seek in whatever system
it is that you're interested in and
hopefully it'll also pick up something
about
the basis of various eye diseases
so I'm going to be talking to you today
about three different conditions
so starting up at the top there
um diabetic retinopathy so this
condition is the uh the most common
cause of vision loss amongst those of
working age
and it affects both the vasculature in
the retina the back of the eye
particularly the microvascular but also
the neural retina as well
um
I'll also talk about glaucoma so this
can cause a permanent
um vision loss due to damage occurring
to the retinal ganglion axons as they
leave the eye and the optic nerve
and finally I'll talk about age-related
macular degeneration which is a terrible
condition which causes loss of your
essential High Acuity vision and the
name suggests this is more prevalent
among older people so approximately five
percent of those over 65 and over 10
percent of those over 80 affected by
age-related macular degeneration
foreign
with a diabetic retinopathy and as I
mentioned this is often thought of as
perhaps primarily a vascular disease so
we get dysfunction of the
microvasculature
um which becomes leaky and can lead to a
buildup of fluid um in the back of the
eye or edema which can cause vision loss
and then in the in the later stages in
advanced diabetic retinopathy we can
actually get proliferation of the
vessels which causes uh major loss of
vision however there's also uh damage to
the various cell types in the neural
retina
this is perhaps less well characterized
and there's something of a debate as to
either to a link to the problems with
the vasculature cause the neural damage
or does it happen independently and
which happens first so this is the
question that we tried to address with
our study
so we used a mouse model of type 1
diabetes
in which you we use streptositosin
injections which uh destroy the beta
cells in the pancreas and the mice
become diabetic so after three time
periods of uh three weeks four months or
six months I'll refer to that as early
mid and late periods
um so this is length of diabetes we
sacrificed the mice dissected out the
retina and then isolated the individual
retinal cells which you can see in the
image in the bottom right
so this took some optimization because
this is um as I'm sure you'll hear from
other speakers this is really a critical
step in single cell RNA sequencing
experiments we need to have high
viability
um cells but even with this there will
be some damage and rnas built from the
cells so they'll be ambient RNA which is
particularly a problem in retinal
studies so that these experiments were
performed using the 10x genomics in the
platform
so we analyzed the data using a standard
cell Ranger
from 10x and Surat version 3 Pipeline
with the normal air quality control
steps
and you can see from
um this umap image of the different
cells I should say with um
approximately uh 10 000 cells here and
each dot in the U map is an individual
cell that are clustered together
according to similarity of their
transcriptomes and we've got quite nice
separation of all the various cell types
so you can see in the cartoon diagram on
the right hand side what those different
cell types are and this is adapted from
the seminal paper by mccosko at our
which was the first group to use a drop
seek to analyze the retina so we're
quite happy with our initial results so
we've got a very nice resolution of the
different cell types
um this kind of raises the question of
how many actual cell types or clusters
of cells are there what is the best way
to define the different cell types
and so we used the initially the default
settings on Surat and we have
approximately 50
um different clusters
which you can see indicated here
but this number can change depending on
the settings and there are some ways you
can try and determine the optimum number
but in some senses it's up to you to
decide the granularity of your
clustering and this you need to think
about uh depends on on your question so
all these multiple cell types are very
useful and we've looked at those and it
provides some information
um about the potential roles of the
different subtypes
um
so in the in the default settings we
have let's say we had about 50
um different
clusters and by looking at the marker
genes we could assign those in the
middle U map there to the different cell
types so the subtypes of the main
classes of cells armor crimes bipolar
and so on so as I say this is very
useful but one thing that we became
aware of is that as you make smaller and
smaller clusters you have less cells and
this then gives you with less power to
look at differential expression so
sometimes it's beneficial to do a more
coarse clustering as we have on the
right hand side where we group for
example all the rod cells together and
then we can perform differential
expression between the control and the
diabetic and have more power to find
differentially expressed genes
but before even considering actual
differential expression of genes one of
the great Paths of single cell analysis
of a complex tissue is that we have the
numbers of cells from all the different
cell types and we can look at the
proportions of those individual cells
and that's what's shown in this
visualization here
so just to orientate you so each of the
Dots here represents an individual cell
and then
the if you look firstly vertically we
have each of the cell types our macline
bipolar and so on and then the two rows
indicate the control cells and those
from the diabetic mice so as you can see
the patterns are very similar so we've
obviously the same cell types but the
number of
um
each subtype of cell within those
indicated by the different colors are
also fairly similar so in fact we had no
significantly different changes in
proportions
and if they just focus now
uh on two of the cell types so on the
right hand side you see the rod cells
and there are slightly uh fewer in the
diabetic retina although it wasn't
significant with the numbers that we had
but if we now look at the size of each
of the individual spots so remember each
uh start or dot represents the cell but
the size of that is in this case is
being determined by the number of
features so the number of different
genes being expressed by those cells
this is a reflection both of the cell
size so if they're small obviously we'll
have less genes and also the diversity
of genes being expressed so in the rod
cells that we see highlighted on the
right they're very small dots because
these cells are and cell body anyway
it's very small and also it it they
express a small range of genes that to a
very high expression level whereas the
ganglion cells that are outlined age
individuals
um spot is bigger because they're larger
cells with a wide wider range of genes
expressed this is just
um reminding you this extra information
available from single cell RNA set data
that you can look into
coming back to the differential
expression so now this is at each time
point we have three three uh Mice from
the control and diabetic so we separated
out these cell types and then looked at
the differential Gene um expression and
I'm just showing the results from some
of the more abundant cell types because
it it's difficult to compare with the
rarer cell types unfortunately there
were too few vascular cells to give a
very significant changes
but if you look we see the different
cells seems to be responding in
different ways so the rods for example
have most changes at the later time
Point indicated in red in the diagram
whereas armor crime cells seem to be
affected their gene expression early on
at the early time point and then not so
much later on and again the Muller cells
are the most
changes later on
so if we just focus on that a little bit
more so the amoclaim cells at the early
time point so I've pulled out the most
differential Express genes with most
significant changes and these are almost
entirely fell into these two groups
which indicated with the
um green surround are components of the
ribosome and each of the genes in this
network
um
the color indicates the relative
expression between the in the in the
normal and the diabetic so the blue
color means
um that the various ribosomal
um genes have gone down early on in our
McLean cells the suggesting that they're
reducing their protein synthesis whereas
genes associated with the mitochondria
are increased in it
um expression so presumably it was more
electron transport and ATP generation
occurring
if we compare this with a later time
point with the two cell types I
mentioned before the mulliglia and the
rods so again we have changes in gene
expression of the mitochondria genes but
in at this time point they
um are reducing an expression and
there's less obvious changes in ribosome
but as you can see in this small Network
there are many other genes also affected
so there's more diverse effects of
delayed time points here as one might
expect
so we can see that showing it in this
image
so if you look on the left hand side
we've looked at again at five of the
more numerous cell types
so the rods molar glare but also the
bipolar the other photoreceptors the
cones and amocrine neurons so you can
see uh that there are
um some functions seem to be altered in
many of the cell types such as the
respiratory electron the transport and
ATP synthesis that I showed you before
and also uh protein synthesis functions
but there are also
um other Pathways and uh types of
function that are also
altered but just in some of the cell
types and these are
currently under study so these are as
yet unpublished data
so this is also borne out if we look at
the circus plot on the right hand side
um what this indicates for each of these
cell types labeled there is a number of
altered genes so the longer the
proportion of the circle the more genes
are altered in that cell type and the
purple lines join
the same genes that are altered in
different cell types so I think what
this shows is that that certain cell
types such as a rod and bipolar and even
the mulliglia have many genes which are
altered and fairly specifically in those
particular cell types so although there
are shared effects and different cell
types are also differentially
affected by diabetes
so shift now to focus a little bit more
on the retinal Microbus lifter which is
the the main type of cell affected in
diabetic retinopathy so they're known to
um
become leaky during the pathology so we
wanted to look in a bit more detail and
you can see from this one image that
there is heterogeneity in the expression
of certain in this case proteins but
presumably the underlying messenger RNA
and different cells so to do this we
used
um a cell culture model a primary bovine
retinol microvascular endothelial cells
and in this case it's using the fluid
ion platform and a full length
transcriptome
uh which is measured using the smart
seat protocol indicated in the diagram
on the right so this allows us to look a
little more a bit more detail about some
aspects of messenger RNA not possible
with the 10x platform it just looks at
the three prime ends so most of this
work has been uh published in Maldives
so
when we did initial clustering of the
cells they're very clearly fell into two
clusters if you look on the left hand
side
and there's a small group of sounds that
were clearly proliferating
but it's possible to regress that cell
cycle effects and if you look at the U
map on the right that's what we've done
with these cells and you can see there's
a fairly homogeneous population just
forming this one large cluster which
seems to not be affected by batch
effects from the different animals or to
different batches that we ran the
experiment in so a fairly homogeneous
population of endothelial cells
so what we're particularly interested in
is the barrier function so the
connections between the end of the your
cells because this is what becomes
dysfunctional in diabetes so we use the
gene expression data from the Single
Cell RNA seek to see which of the many
known potential components of the
barrier were expressed and this diagram
indicates those that are expressed and
at what level at least the messenger RNA
and this is confirmed for some of the
genes using them in the Mr chemistry
I mean it would be possible to generate
this model using bulk or an Asic data
but because this is single cell
we can extract some more information and
just got some examples of the barrier
genes from the previous slide here and
their expression level so again each dot
indicates the expression in individual
cell you can see there are some some
genes that are highly expressed in all
the cells and then some in the middle
there the dfc2 for example are expressed
at moderate levels and some sales are
not at all in others
so what this allows us to do is then
look for correlation between the
expression of different genes so what
the correlation on the on the right is
showing us for
um the barrier genes just is which genes
are expressed in the same pattern uh
together between different cells so what
genes are low in some cells and then
high in another cell and so on so follow
the same expression pattern
I mean we can see when we look at the
most highly correlated genes uh on the
very top right of the slide you see that
red square so those are a small number
of genes have seen the center on pcam1
that expressed similar similar levels
together so we need to be careful not to
over interpret this but it at least as
evidence uh suggestive evidence that
these genes may be functioning together
and that this is something we can you
know then investigate further
so the final bit of data to show you
from these experiments is about
alternative splicing because as I
mentioned the uh this work we have full
lengths transcripts
so we can then look at slicing right
along the length of the transcript so
I've got examples from two genes here
add one and snap 23.
and I've chosen just four cells
illustrators cells uh to show you the
alternative splicing
so
um
I've highlighted here the exons which
are spliced in some transcripts and not
in others so if you look at add one at
the very top in the first cell the
transcripts all go from the left hand X
on to the right hand axon so there's a
percentage spliced in value of zero so
in that cell all transcripts don't have
the additional X on
well just be looked down to cell four
and add one for example all the
transcripts have that um
Exon spliced in whereas in cell 2 is a
bit of a mixture and the numbers on the
right hand side
177 at the top there is a number of
reads we have
um for each event so
I think there's reasonably strong
evidence that this is occurring and it's
quite exciting that in some cells we
seem to get
almost exclusively one-eye the form and
in other cells of different isoform
um
and depending obviously on the Gene and
the X on this may change the Protein
that's been encoded
so again we need to be a little bit
cautious with some of these results
because it is difficult
um to be too uh certain because of the
um
that level of difficulties of measuring
changes in an individual cell but I
think this is a very exciting prospect
for a more studies alternative splicing
at the Single Cell level in the future
okay so now I'm going to tell you a bit
about a study
um
where we looked at some of the causes of
age-related Immaculate degeneration I've
mentioned that one of the cell types
involved in that is the retinal pigment
epithelium which are the cells formal
layer at the bottom of the retina so AMD
is multifactorial and there's many
factors involved but one of the key
pathologies is the development of these
um
the so-called Jews and deposits which
occur between the rpe and the rest of
the sorry on the basement membrane on
which they sit at the bottom of the
retina so you can see in the image on
the right hand side the two stars
indicate these Drews and deposits and
the dark glare is the retinal pigment
epithelium and the neural retina above
that so the RP should form a flat layer
but in this case the drewsin are formed
underneath
so um collaborator imray lenga and
others have shown that if you grow
primary human RP cells long-term in
culture they develop many of the uh
phenotype similar to that in Vivo in
fact you can model the formation of
these trues and
but in these models and in Vivo there's
evidence that it's heterogeneity in the
rpe cells so we wanted to use single
cell analysis to understand the
pathology and this model in more detail
so this is an outline of the
um experiment that we performed
so these RP cells were grown in Long uh
term codes either for just a couple of
weeks several months or up to five
months and you can see the images the
cells below there and the longer they're
in culture they become pigmented but
there is this heterogeneity in some
cells are more pigmented than others
and the trans epithelial resistance of
the cells also increases with time which
is an indication of their mature
phenotype
so
um this is the initial clustering of
approximately 20 000 cells from all
combined together from those different
time points and you can see we've got a
reasonably homogeneous
um cluster and the different libraries
from the different cell uh different
times
overlap quite a lot although I'll come
back to that a little bit later so we're
reasonably happy with the experiment I
don't seem to be any batch effects for
example at this stage
so then this came back to the question
of the clustering how many clusters
should we have
so using the default pipeline we end up
with approximately 13 clusters as shown
in the bottom right there but you can
vary the resolution of your clustering
algorithm and generate a fewer clusters
so we'll kind of uh wondering what was
the best answer so we can look at the 13
clusters and this can provide
information about sub-specialization of
the different cell types
but are they really all um different uh
meaningful cell types
so we then looked at the expression of
some known RP genes and there appear to
be two main main groups so uh sort of
left hand
area of the plot or cluster seem to be
high expression of the rpe genes
known RP genes and if we also look down
at the libraries in terms of the time
points we see that the long-term culture
indicated in blue in this plot seems to
be more in the left hand part of the
plot which seems to again correlate with
the more mature phenotype
so
to investigate this uh that we generated
list of genes that have been associated
with the rpe in either from the
literature or previous
experimental studies and then we
performed
um clustering so you can see on the heat
map on the right hand side
and the heat map shows the average gene
expression
um for each of the Clusters shown in the
U map there and it this clearly fell
into two groups and the Clusters
co-locate with the two half if you like
of the U map and I just indicated some
of the
um best known
RP Mark genes at the top right hand
corner there and they're located in the
uh what have indicated the red cluster
which is the left and one in the diagram
which equates to the more mature cells
so in terms of our rpe phenotype
it seems that we actually have two main
subclusters
on the right hand side or the left
differentiated cells in red and then
more differentiated is the large cluster
on the left
foreign
this was interesting for us and
obviously we can now perform
differential expression between these
two populations and this will as well as
showing us some known RP genes
potentially along without this some
other genes involved in RPA function
that we're discovering
and also what we looked at was the
proportions of these two populations of
less differentiated more differentiated
cells at the different time points
so if you look at the graph in the
bottom right hand corner so we're going
from the shortest time point of a couple
of weeks up to the longer time points
after five months and you can see that
the proportion of more differentiated
cells increases with time so it seems
that the more mature phenotype that we
generate with long-term culture is not
so much that all the cells become
gradually more mature it's that there's
a greater proportion of the more mature
um subtype so this now allows us to
interpret the experiments using this
model more effectively and it also
potentially has in Vivo relevance
because I haven't showed it here but
there's some evidence these
subpopulations actually exist in Vivo
so having these two uh cell populations
also allowed us to study the transition
between the less differentiated to more
differentiated so the maturation process
if you like so for this we use the
pseudo time analysis using the uh
monocle software
so what this does is aligns all the
cells along this trajectory from the
least differentiated to the most
differentiated
when we focus on the principle
trajectory which goes from the start
Point indicated in blue there in the
right hand figure and winds its way to
the most differentiated cells in red on
the left hand side
so all the cells are lined up along this
trajectory and then we can look at
hygiene expression changes along that
maturation gradient if you like
uh and this is just an overview of the
results
so what we have here are groups of genes
which is described as modules so each
horizontal
um panel here is the average expression
of a group of genes that all have
similar patterns of gene expression as
we move from
um
less differentiated cells on the left
hand side to the more differentiated on
the right hand side so we kind of have a
pseudo time going from left to right
so you can see there's essentially two
groups of genes those that are higher in
the less differentiated so the red ones
on the left the bottom and genes which
are higher in the more differentiated so
that's on the right hand side at the top
so we could have found a lot of these
genes by just comparing an expression as
I mentioned previously between the less
and the more differentiated but this
pseudo time gives us some more
information
and perhaps the most interesting genes
are those ones that I've highlighted in
the middle here which seem to have
increased expression just around a
period of the of the transition between
less to more differentiated so these are
the genes that are most likely to tell
us about
um how this transition Works rather than
being just characteristic
um of the two populations themselves so
these are genes that are up now and uh
further investigation
okay so the final study that I just
finished off briefly telling you about
involves some preliminary work looking
at the causes of glaucoma
so as I mentioned before glaucoma
um
causes permanent loss of vision and uh
reduction in your visual field and this
is due to Progressive degeneration of
the retinal ganglion itself
so the pathogenesis is not well
understood and it's often but not always
related to elevated ocular pressure
um in particular area that's come under
focus is the lamina fibrosa which is
shown in the diagram on the right so the
retinal ganglion cell axons spread
across the surface of the retina and
bringing the signals from the visual
process out through the optic nerve back
to the brain so it's where these retinal
dangling cell axons go through the
optic nerve of this region called the
laminate cabroza where it started damage
occurs this is kind of a sieve-like
structure which helps to control a
pressure differential between inside and
outside
um the eye
so uh there's some evidence to suggest
that part of the pathology is an
increase in extracellular Matrix
deposition by the laminate cabros that
cells which are indicated just in the
top right of the cartoon diagram there
so
it's possible to grow these cells and
culture so what we asked was are there
some populations of laminate corrosis
cells and how do they change in glaucoma
so primary cultures were prepared of
laminar browser cells from donors
without up to the disease and those with
glaucoma
part of the reason I wanted to just show
you this study was because we used
genetic D multiplexing using the
d-maxlet algorithm published by kangata
so what this uses is the genetic
difference between the individuals in
the study so the the cells from the
different individuals are pulled
together as you see in the in the center
of the diagram of the right and on the
right
and then whenever we do the sequencing
as well as counting the number of genes
we can also look at the Snips That Vary
between the different individuals they
also perform bulk RNA seeds from the
same samples so that we knew which Snips
related to which individual that and
this allows you to demultiplex at the
sample on the bottom right hand side
there
um
it's possible to do something similar to
this with any samples Now using
so-called cell hashing techniques or the
cellplex
um protocol from 10x where you
artificially label your different
samples
so this approach has several advantages
first of all it allows you to spot
doublets so that's where we have
um more than one cell going to the same
droplet
and we obviously want to remove those
and that can be quite difficult
otherwise but if there's a mixture of
snacks we can throw those out also
because you're pulling all your samples
and running them together reduces batch
effects and perhaps most importantly you
can reduce the cost by just running one
suspension containing several samples
so the initial clustering here just
demonstrates how it's easy to spot the
doublets in this case the green cells
this is where some cells are stuck
together and we're getting one and one
in a droplet so we can remove those and
repeat the clustering
we can see that in this case we got four
principal cell clusters and then if you
look at
um how the individual
um or spread throughout these clusters
so the different colored dots on the
right hand side indicate cells from
different individuals so we've got a
spread right across the different groups
as you might expect the cells from the
glaucoma patients seem to be focused
primarily in one cluster which seems to
have some gene expression suggested
being a kind of an activated fibroblasts
like phenotype
so then just to summarize what I've told
you and make some conclusions
so the diabetic retinopathy study using
a mouse model of type 1 diabetes I think
is a nice illustration of of how this
technique allows you to isolate
individual cell types from a complex
tissue which is just not possible any
other way
and just a note to remind people that
the power to detect differential
expression obviously depends on the
number of cells so this is something you
need to consider in your experimental
design and potentially try to enrich the
certain cell types
the most obvious findings that we
discovered in this study were the
metabolic changes with
um mitochondrial genes and also
um
protein synthesis there are many other
cell type specific changes that we're
now looking into and just also a note
that
um
depending on the system that you're
looking at it's worth considering
alternative splicing I think this will
be something we'll see more of in the
future and there definitely seem to be
some things going on in the vascular
endothelial cells from the retina
so in the AMD study looking at
um RP cells in culture
this really clarified the system for us
and showed that some populations present
in cell culture which these single cell
experiments have now enabled us to
interpret the experiments more
effectively and also have insights into
the in Vivo being a type
so in terms of glaucoma I think this is
interesting that the subpopulations of
cells persist in primary culture of the
laminate browser and this preliminary
results suggest this may provide some
insights into the glaucoma phenotype
so just to give an overall conclusion uh
probably everyone really is already a
single cell RNA Sig obviously provides
unique insights not other ways possible
um but each study you do is different so
before you embark on a new study you
really need to think about the
hypothesis and the question that you're
asking to guide the experimental design
obviously
um
I think it's a very exciting field but
so many breakthroughs already just with
the technology I've talked about uh and
I think you'll be hearing from the other
speakers about the developments of
multi-ohmics looking at protein at the
same time on spatial transdermics and
this is certainly something we'll be
doing now to further
um the studies that I've described to
you
so just to finish off with some
acknowledgments to the members of my own
own group and Professor Tim Curtis who's
worked closely on the diabetic
retinopathy study in Ray lingard
on the rpe work and Columbo O'Brien from
University College Dublin who has been
doing the work on glaucoma
so thanks very much for your attention